all right our next speaker is Christina
Aventa from Harvard who's been speaking
about mic recording for individual
fairness okay thank you for having me
here this talk definitely falls on the
beyond category and what I'd like to
talk about today is some of my recent
work on metric learning from human
judgments to try to power individual
fairness so lucky for me Michael and gal
get really nice talks yesterday and kind
of introduced this idea of maybe what
individual fairness is some of the
definitions in the literature but just
to review individual fairness roughly
says that we want to treat similar
people similarly and how do we define
similarity well we assume that we have
some metric which is a function that
tells us the distance between any pair
of individuals and that distance
corresponds to how similar they are for
particular classification tasks so what
we might say more formally to define
individual fairness is that a classifier
is individually fair if for every pair
of individuals their difference in
treatment by that classifier is bounded
by their distance in the metric so if
two people are very similar for example
they're very similar in applying for a
job for which they're very similarly
qualified individual fairness would
require that their probability of
getting that job or being invited for an
interview should be similar but on the
other hand if they have wildly different
qualifications it would be okay to
invite them with with different
probabilities so roughly speaking this
is what we mean by individual fairness
any questions before I go on this
notation isn't terribly important but if
there's any notation throughout the talk
that's confusing please feel free to
stop me okay
so individual fairness as a definition
entirely relies on this metric right all
of the constraints come from having
distances which tell us how similar
individuals are and in some sense this
makes individual friend is a really
powerful definition so in particular we
get very strong individual level
guarantees so what this means is that we
write this definition is over every pair
of individuals we have this constraint
so every individual will get
a guarantee on their treatment with
respect to every other individual so in
particular this doesn't let us do things
like justify treatment based on group
membership or say you know I'm very
sorry that you were treated badly don't
worry someone else in another group was
treated badly too so instead we really
have to be disciplined about giving
guarantees for every pair of individuals
okay so the second thing that's really
great about the metric is that it's an
explicit entry point for human judgement
and it's an explicit entry point for
nuanced human judgement so instead of
being restricted to some predefined set
of features or protected attributes or
groups instead we can have as much or as
little nuance as we like to tell us who
is similar to whom and therefore what
guarantees on treatment should we be
giving another really nice part of this
and and bringing this nuance in is that
we are not required to define fairness
in terms of accuracy or in terms of
statistical properties so we heard some
really good examples yesterday where we
might have a very accurate risk
predictor but we're not actually happy
with the idea of treating people only
based on this predicted risk even if
it's very accurate because we feel like
it's not acceptable to predetermine
someone's life based on a genetic
condition or something like this so in
some sense individual fairness really
relies on the metric that's where all of
its power comes from but it gives us a
really great way to say what we mean
when we're talking about fairness to not
kind of have things at this very
abstract level it allows us to have a
lot of nuance okay so why are we giving
this talk then if this metric is so
great well the question is where does
this metric come from right in the
original paper in that section I I
highlighted before it wasn't really
clear where this metric comes from but
there was some desire to have it be
public and open to discussion so the
whole point of this talk is to think
about how we can actually get our hands
on a metric by using human judgments and
for those human judgments the core of
this talks are going to rely on
something that I'm going to call human
fairness arbiter so I'm gonna assume
that I have
access to some human fairness arbiters
who in particular are free from explicit
biases and arbitrary biases so they're
not just necessarily not particularly
racist or something but they also don't
have like a hometown school bias we're
also going to assume that they are
motivated to engage ethically and
honestly in our protocol we're not going
to worry about them trying to trip us up
and that they're knowledgeable about the
task at hand in any historical context
they might need to actually evaluate
similarity finally we're not going to
actually ask these arbiters to tell us
why they're answering a particular way
we're just going to ask them to answer
some well form questions this is very
similar to some related work with I
think what was called the philosopher
friend and I'm wasn't piping so this is
like the term that Cynthia use to
describe the term you use so sorry about
that but there is some some other really
good related work what was the term
think of it as the philosopher friend
but like this is not the accurate term
where the idea is that we're in this
online setting and someone can give us
some binary feedback signal of whether
we've done it right or not but they
don't have to tell us why and so this is
a very similar similar model to that
okay so the interesting question is
assuming that we have access to these
these arbiters like the remainder of
this talk is focused on we have this set
of people that we can ask that can give
us these good judgements how do we
actually use them to produce a metric
and it turns out that how we ask and
what we ask really matters so different
query types have very different
difficulty levels for humans right if I
ask you to look at I don't know the
faculty in the room to consider two
perspective grad students and tell me
please give me a distance between 0 and
100 which tells me how similar these
graduate students are for being hired
for lab I mean it's all it's almost an
impossible question is not necessarily
impossible but it's very difficult so if
I asked you to give me real value
distances between individuals you could
probably do it but
difficult it might take you a long time
and in particularly you might have to
remember what you said before in order
to answer questions I asked you later on
the other hand I could ask you relative
distance queries so I could say you know
here are three perspective grad students
Alice Bob and Charlie is Alice more
similar to Bob or more similar to
Charlie and in some sense these
questions are easier to answer because
it's giving you essentially a binary
question it's a relative distance you
don't have to put a number on it and you
don't have to be consistent with any
numbers that you've given before so
throughout this talk we're going to
assume that these are really the only
two types of queries we can ask
so in particular we can't ask the
arbiter to please tell me the closest
pair of individuals in the universe or
the farthest pair of individuals in the
universe or anything like that we're
gonna restrict ourselves to these two
query types but we're going to assume
that relative distance queries are much
much less expensive in terms of like the
human query cost than real valued
distances okay so a quick mental model
at least a mental model that I use when
I think about how are we asking human
beings about similarity is that when we
have an arbiter they're very good at
looking at a high dimensional
representation of a person for example
something like a college application
which has freeform text it has GPA test
scores all the classes you've taken it's
a very high dimensional representation
of a person but they're good at bringing
this into the low dimensional
representation of the salient features
for the task at hand so for example is
something like your underlying talent
and your work ethic so it's not
necessarily that they're computing these
very complicated functions over high
dimensional feature vectors but more
that they're able to kind of intuitively
make this translation and then they're
able to make comparisons in that kind of
heuristic space okay so this whole talk
is about learning metrics from these
human arbiters and yeah sort of like the
description of how they can arrive at
their own thoughts about the fairness of
their own decisions that's a really good
question and so
the way that I think about this is so I
think about this more from like the how
difficult is it perspective rather than
like does this make you feel like you're
giving good judgments or bad judgments
so I would say that I think of this as a
mental model I don't have any evidence
that this is actually how people are
doing this or any strong evidence but so
the idea is that if what really matters
for a task is is somewhat more low
dimensional that I'm assuming that human
beings are able to evaluate that that
really the fairness of are these two
people similar or not is kind of more of
an emotional or intuitive judgment that
human beings are making rather than
something that we're gonna write out as
a very very complicated function over a
high dimensional feature vectors does
that make sense you are defining some
measure of success so it doesn't
necessarily have to be a measure of
success it has to be a measure of what
we as a society think constitutes
similarity for the task
so for hiring maybe it is maybe our view
as a society is what makes people
similar when they're applying for jobs
is their likelihood of success in that
job but I don't want to particularly
tell you exactly how that has to be
that's something I'm relying on the
arbiter to have the right intuitive
sense of is that is that answering your
question at all
I think it's a bigger question okay it's
fine I'm gonna bid other people out too
but I'm just going to say that you know
one of the things that you find about
people is that even within individuals
that the answer to that question is
change right right and that's that's
actually a really good point which I
hope everyone the audience heard and I
just want to repeat you might have
people change their opinions over time
the arbiters might you know today have a
particular opinion that opinion may
change over time or the way that you
measure it might change over time but in
some sense how are you going to do
better if the goal is to get at what we
as human beings think constitutes
similarity I'm just gonna ask another
like annoying question about people like
I totally agree with you that it's much
easier to answer questions like is a
more similar to be then you know like
what is the like metric distance between
hey bb-but but I wonder if that's
because like my internal representation
actually like isn't symmetric and you
know you can ask me these easy to answer
questions but you find it look like you
know when you kind of like write them
all down so that that's a really
interesting question and I think to a
large extent by staying away from saying
our metric is Euclidean and this many
dimensions we free ourselves to a large
extent from worrying about things which
are inconsistent so
some sense the methods that I'm going to
present here to a large extent I've
tried to stay very much away from making
strong assumptions about the form of the
metric I don't think it's entirely
accurate to say that this talk doesn't
actually rely on the underlying thing
being a metric but it's not relying on
it very strongly of course we're gonna
use triangle inequality it's the only
thing I use in my research so
essentially we're gonna rely on triangle
inequality but not a lot else although
you know come on what else is Aryan
metrics okay great so these are really
good questions I have no idea how I'm
doing on time so I'm gonna move on but
please feel free to keep interrupting
great okay so what are what am I going
to attempt to do in whatever remaining
time I have so I want to kind of give
you three insights that at least make me
believe there's some hope that we can
make progress on trying to extract
metrics from human beings so the first
is that essentially I don't have to ask
all M squared distances I can use
distances from a single representative
element representative here doesn't have
any sort of like ethical meaning it's
more like I picked an element and I
called it a representative rather than
it has some sort of like electable
qualities but I can use distances from
this single element to produce useful
approximations to the whole metric or
too many distances and then the second
thing is that I can use easy query types
to generate orderings which give me
access to more which lets me pretend
that I asked a bunch of hard queries
when I didn't and then we almost
certainly won't get to this but we can
generalize to unseen samples under
certain assumptions and I think it's
actually really interesting to think
about when those assumptions fail and
what that actually means about fairness
okay so I'll brace through this a little
bit assuming that most people are
familiar with what a metric is so
essentially what we're going to
introduce to approximate this metric is
the notion the notion of a sub metric
and so what a sub metric is essentially
is it's a contraction of the original
metric but it's allowed to overestimate
by some small additive error those of
you who are theory minded in this
audience have already jumped to the idea
that I could just say all distances are
zero and
satisfy this definition that's certainly
true and will give a better definition
of what it actually means to be
non-trivial in a couple of slides but
the basic takeaway here is that it's
okay to move people a little bit closer
together for individual fairness and
we're gonna tolerate a little bit of
additive error to be able to improve our
query complexity okay so our beloved
triangle inequality appears on this
slide so the interesting thing that that
we're going to take advantage of is that
if I have some representative element
and I learn its distances to two other
points I can take the difference in
those distances and I always get an
underestimate on the distance between
the two elements so what this lets us do
is essentially construct a bunch of
distances between every other pair of
elements in the universe by just asking
order n queries so if I just asked order
and realvalue queries I can get an
underestimate for all of the other
distances so again naively I can ask
order and real varied queries we're
definitely doing better than N squared
and then compute this what I'll call a
representative sub metric directly
that's a great question so how do you
choose these representatives roughly
speaking it well it should depend on
what your problem looks like if you
believe you have some structure that you
can choose these representatives well
then that's a good choice what I'll
present if hopefully we get there is
that you can choose random
representatives and then you can get
some properties based on how distances
are distributed in your metric but to
also I'll come back to this and like a
slide or two and please ask again if
it's if it's not getting clear okay so
I'm gonna claim that oh of N is actually
not very good we're still asking a lot
of these hard queries and we want to ask
fewer and we can do better and the way
that we're going to do it is by ordering
and then using a smaller number of
queries to add real values but
tolerating some errors so roughly how
our query strategy looks is that we're
gonna order the elements by using
relative queries as a comparator so I
can use a triplet query
so I'm asking use our closer to X or as
our closer to Y as a comparator so that
I can actually order by distance from R
from and as yet unspecified how I chose
it R so I'm now using n log n triplet
queries for this sort and then I'm going
to ask real valued queries to only get
distances with some granularity alpha so
I'm not gonna try to get any better
precision than plus or minus alpha and
this is going to cost me log in or one
over alpha in order to do this but the
good news is if I round down I will only
introduce errors of at most alpha so I'm
going to label elements at granularity
alpha and then I'm gonna round every one
down that doesn't have an explicit label
to get myself an error of at most alpha
so this is very nice in the sense that
we have gone from N squared to n to log
in real value queries and we did it at
the cost of adding n log n triplet
queries and a bit of additive error so
back to Rachel's excellent question this
is very nice but like if you chose a
representative that was equally distant
from all other elements you don't really
get any distinguishing power between
those elements so in particular you
can't distinguish elements like on
either side of the representative and so
to give this a little bit more of a
rigorous definition like what this
problem is we want sub metrics that are
non-trivial we want them to actually
give us some enough information about
the metric we were trying to reconstruct
so the the notation here is not
important if it doesn't make sense to
you what we're trying to say is that
with at least probability beta a pair
drawn from my distribution will have a
see fraction of the original distance
preserved so for example I could say
with probability at least 90% a pair
drawn from my distribution will have at
least half of their original distance
preserved so this gives us some sense of
like how good of a job are we doing to
approximate the metric very
conservatively we could say that a
representative sub metrics of this idea
of getting all of the distances from a
single representative is only 1 over N
one non trivial so it's preserving all
the distances from each element to the
representative but it's not necessarily
we can
say much else about what it's doing so
very briefly if I have multiple
representatives I can combine the sub
metrics I won't go into the detail much
here but roughly speaking you get the
best possible distance you've seen so
far and you can slightly improve the
query complexity by using a different
relative
yes the biggest did I say the wrong yes
yes so your just want bigger and bigger
and they're all under estimate so that's
okay to use any one of them that you've
seen and in particular the alphas don't
add up
you always get to keep the same the same
alpha bound if you're using the same or
the maximum alpha ok so skip that
alright so what are we so what have we
seen so far so essentially what I've
shown you so far is that we can trade
query types to get better query
complexity but there's two glaring
questions left open which is how do we
choose representatives preserve distance
as well and how might we generalize to
unseen samples so I'm just gonna give
some brief intuition for these two
things that I'm happy to talk about them
offline so the intuition for a
generalization is that instead of trying
to like learn some arbitrary function
some arbitrary distance function I want
to say like suppose that I can learn a
set of mirror verses far functions for
varying levels of near versus far if I
can do that then in particular I can
generate the labels for those functions
using the labeling using the labels that
we would have generated by the queries
we just looked at and then I can feed
those into some learners that I assume I
have for these newer versus for our
functions and put them together
essentially will allow them to vote and
say which of these thresholds we
actually think is most likely to
correctly under ate underestimate the
distance but be the largest distance
which underestimates and then what we
get is that the generalization
guarantees will depend on the
generalization guarantees of the
threshold functions that's a threshold
function learners so to some extent
we're outsourcing our generalization to
this assumption that can I learn near
versus far
and for what levels of interesting near
versus far thresholds can I do this so
like what does it mean but I go what are
you like that what are you learning a
mapping problem
I am outsourcing that to the threshold
functions as well so the way to think
about this is I'm assuming that you have
some representation of people so you
have some feature vector and on that
feature vector you're able to learn
these binary threshold functions if you
can do that then this goes through this
basically says I am hunting very hard on
what that representation actually looks
like and what those threshold owners
actually look like I think this is
important I think your question is
somewhat anticipating you know what if
you don't have these threshold learners
what if the thresholds are really
uninteresting and that I think raises a
question of like when are we really able
to generalize or not and that has a lot
to do with how we're actually
representing the data so this maybe is
perhaps present in a slightly
oversimplified way so that that's a
really good question let's let's
continue in then and then I'll
definitely back to it okay so I just
want to mention one kind of important
tool in particular when we have kind of
potentially uninteresting or weird sets
of near versus far functions that we can
learn so we can use post-processing to
kind of get rid of error if we have too
much air so I have in particular if I
have like a large gap between some
thresholds that I can learn this is
going to impact my maximum error but I
can get rid of it essentially by
post-processing I will be reducing the
overall amount of distance that I'm
preserving but I can basically decide to
trade-off whether I want larger additive
errors or more distance preservation so
this is like a knob that I can choose to
turn so I just wanted to point that out
okay so how can we choose
representatives so I mentioned there
were kind of two ways you could think
about this before so the first is if I
have some sort of like No
or friendly metric form so if I know
that my metric is like a 2d Euclidean
metric I can essentially play GPS and I
can pick representatives in a way that I
can uniquely identify where everyone
lives in this 2d space based on their
distances from the representative so
this is entirely reasonable or
strategies like this are reasonable if
you know something about the metric form
if you don't or if you know something
but it's not necessarily friendly in
this way you can essentially choose
representatives at random and the non
triviality and sample complexity
guarantees you will get are related to
the distribution of distances in the
metric I won't go into too much detail
here but happy to talk about it offline
right and so the key thing that makes
this work is if I choose a random set of
representatives and they do a good job
of being kind of near to one half of
each pair that I care about I'll get
I'll be able to recover good distances
for the pairs that have at least one
element in your representative thanks
for a good old friend the triangle
inequality okay so roughly what we've
done in this talk is essentially talk
about like technical ideas for trying to
get information from human beings and
use it efficiently to come up with
metrics so roughly what we did was we
showed that you can estimate distances
for the entire universe by looking at
distances from a small set of
Representative points we talked about
combining different query types to try
to reduce the number of hard queries and
trade them off for easy queries and then
we talked a little bit about how you
might try to generalize beyond just like
a thick sample where you can actually
ask the arbiter questions about the
people involved I'll end with some
really brief questions on food for
thought I'm sure you guys have had more
year so what should we do when arbiters
disagree this may be a feature not a bug
you may mean we don't actually know what
we think is fair as a society what
should we do if the arbiters agree but
we aren't able to generalize is this
maybe some indication that all the
humans agree but we aren't able to
actually learn a distance function which
is accurately representing what we think
is fair and do we want to be putting
systems out where this is the case
do we decide who should be interpreter I
managed to punt on that all the way
until the end I can't believe no one
called me on that yes yes exactly
we already know who they should be how
do we trade off different types of error
and then I think a really interesting
question that hasn't come up much maybe
in this workshop is how do we actually
design the systems to collect these
judgments like what can we do to make
sure when we're asking these types of
questions presenting information to the
arbiters that were as much as possible
reducing implicit biases or at least
doing our best to understand how much
implicit bias is creeping in okay and I
promise this at the end I wanted to
highlight some related works if you
thought that this was even remotely
interesting here are four their papers
that I think are highly related to this
topic and kind of explore different
things so I already mentioned the the
first paper our online learning with an
unknown fairness metric so this is
taking a really similar view I think
Marin can correct me if this is
misinterpreting - asking humans
potentially kind of like easy questions
and not asking them to explain
themselves what can we do with that
information
that's scooped on Lumi this is not
necessarily fairness related but it is
related to getting human feedback and
using it efficiently and then the the
last two papers are kind of looking at
this idea of like how do we generalize
in an individually fair way so these are
very good follow-ups if you're
interested in this topic how do you how
do you get a sense of the scaling of the
metro um I think I I lost some important
anchor point like how do you write so if
you ask about drivel valued queries how
do you translate between different
people
right right okay this is a great
question it was amazing I just like yes
let me okay this is sorry this is gonna
take a really long time but while it's
happening I'll try to explain so
essentially what we're doing is we're
using the relative queries as a
comparator we're getting an ordering and
then we're layering here we go and then
we're layering the real values on top of
the ordering right so the the relative
queries are just generating and ordering
we're not actually using them to say
like I'm not using a relative query to
say that this guy is like much further
from this guy than that guy or anything
like that we're just using it to get the
ordering and then we have to use the
realvalue queries on top to give us some
sense of like where these distances
actually are where the scale is this
gets us so thanks for coming back I
didn't catch it but this brings us the
thing because maybe the question I
wanted to ask which is here like people
you know you're asking possibly
different arbiters question they all
have to kind of agree on scale and
there's a sense in which scale here is
meaningless except for the fact that it
comes with a requirement on the the city
comes with a similarity of treatment
requirement right right maybe I'm not a
good choice for the arbiter but this is
a really good point so I I think if I
can maybe recap like it's essentially
like concern or like this feels kind of
trippy if I'm asking to understand this
scale understanding this scale is
important in that if I said you know
everyone in all of these guys are very
very close to the representative it's
only as one guy who's very very far away
I need to know that level of scale in
order to actually be able to do anything
interesting from a fairness perspective
but how do I determine a scale if I'm
asking multiple different arbiters for
real values between zero and one right
like how do I map between those people
is that is that the concern
like what is what is the numerical it's
it's one thing to ask me for comparison
as hard as that is it's hard to be
consistent triangle inequality whatever
here the distance is going to if I give
you a if you ask me for distance query
and I think really hard about it and I
say ok the distance between these two is
like 26 right how are you going to
interpret that you're going to use it in
your plug it into the fairness
definition to say that the probabilities
of admission to you know college I work
at be within eetu the you know whatever
there's some you know there's some
connection to real real actual
probabilities yes that somehow I have to
like make that judgment at right so
here's yeah so here's the way that I
would sort of think about attacking this
but I think this is an interesting this
is an interesting HCI problem as well as
an interesting question of like how do
we want these probabilities to look like
but the way that I would think about
doing this is I would say like dear
arbiter suppose that the distance
between the red guy and the blue guy is
1 please tell me the distance between
I'm gonna ask you about distances
real-valued distances between these
others and so the hope is that maybe you
can anchor and say like relatively are
these much much closer than these two or
you know they're they're actually not
that much closer so in some sense I
think the way that I would like to
handle this is to say give me your best
guess at the actual real value distances
now let's look at the relative
treatments that that actually imposes on
people are you happy with this or not so
I think in some sense there is an
additional layer of understanding so in
some sense you may be able to tell me I
really strongly think that the real
value is 0.5 but in terms of that being
translated into a probability that step
may be more difficult so I do think
there is potentially a second layer on
top of looking at I have you know given
a bunch of real value distances I may
even be very confident in them that
doesn't necessarily mean that I
with the relative treatments that come
out of combining all of these things
come together it's a point you have to
ask society how similar in your metric
do two people have to be free to be
uncomfortable with them getting
differential treatment at this rate of
different key audience um what your
tight metric into the actual
probabilities the end of Adams question
there which they say even once you get
people to have that consistent distance
metrics used it then translate that into
the furnace through awareness absolutely
right and that's something yes so I
think that this largely comes up so
there are two questions that I think
this raises so one it raises I looked in
the scale between zero and one but I
don't actually know what that means in
terms of like the realistic treatment
that people are receiving and human
beings don't necessarily model a number
line between 0 and 1 as like a uniform
model like line between 0 and 1 so I
think that there are likely people in
social sciences who have a lot more
intelligent things to say and I think
one of them has their hands raised about
how we ought to go about trying to model
you've given me numbers between 0 & 1
but what did you really mean in terms of
who is too similar to be treated
differently at all versus who is similar
enough that given the this outcome space
like I think the other thing that we
tend to kind of ignore a little bit in
individual fairness is how different are
the outcomes I think this came up a
little bit yesterday and the preference
and form fairness that understanding how
different those outcomes are and how we
value those outcomes differently I think
that that is a second layer that this is
not addressing that does need to be
addressed I wondered whether your
real-valued queries should actually
incorporate that additional stuff direct
right right that's that's a really
interesting question I don't know
there's a way of doing it that's like
somehow invariant to
transformations the line right like the
metric the concept of metric is is kind
of brittle in that very specific
perspective
Thanks a lot of what you're doing could
also be done with ways of the form are
these two people within distance alpha
or yes yeah I guess you can probably run
it's pretty much something very close to
your item just with those kinds of
queries right you choose the sample to
be just asking are these two similar
enough that they should be treated
within each other right so there's
there's a second yes there's essentially
a second version of this model where the
arbiter is allowed to say too close to
call where these two individuals are two
similar that I'm not willing to give you
a distinction between them or these two
these two distances that you're asking
me to say which distance is bigger than
the other they're too similar I'm going
to refuse I'm going to say I can't tell
you
so in some times we could say like well
let's try to abuse that model and set
different levels of the too close to
call threshold maybe that actually isn't
abusive maybe if we're giving people
like a good grounding and like what
different types of treatments were
really proposing for the different
levels for too close to call
maybe that's totally fine so I so the
nice thing is it does go through you
don't need to have this exact type of
comparison you can introduce the
scientist I want to get to your question
now I'm sorry I've been ignoring you no
pressure no pressure so I actually think
you need to define some because if you
don't say what it
you have to say similar relative to
something first of all and the reason I
think about that is you know the child
psychologist you know prj yo put used to
put kids in the Fontan different check
flocks and toys and so some kids would
group them according to color some of
the people according to you know
different things you know and what he
was trying to figure out was what was
their underlying person or whatever it
was but you you have to define similar
to something and surveys the other thing
that that I worry a little bit about is
this assumption essentially of
transitivity right that if a is closer
to B and a is prepared to be and B is
preferred to C then a must be preferred
to see so that just really briefly
that's actually not required in this so
maybe I can clarify it we're asking is a
more similar to B or is a more similar
to see that doesn't imply anything about
the similarity between B and C right
right right so I am requiring that you
answer questions consistently like if I
ask you the same question twice you need
to give me the same answer
yeah for there are three pairs and I
asked you for all pairwise comparisons
between those three pairs you have to
answer
right so in in some sense it in
sometimes you do measure it's like a
metric has to exist yeah so so that
there's a question of is this arising
due to like error
is it arising due to it's not really a
metric underlying this so I think those
are two kind of different questions in
some sense not a lot of this is really
depending too much on that but I take
your point well particularly with with
respect to what is the similarity with
respect to we I think frequently assumed
that we've really well like we've
defined a really like clear task like
I'm applying for a job at company X in
this position so we sometimes kind of
fall into this idea of thinking we have
this really well-defined task it's so
clear who is similar to whom there would
never be you know different people
wouldn't ever have like different views
of that and so I think that this is a
really important question that I'm not
sure we're going to be able to answer
until we actually start asking human
beings or we find kind of I'm using
words similar way too much but similar
studies that are kind of at the same
level of specificity that are still
running into this problem of are you you
know organizing by shape or by color and
it's not entirely clear to me that that
we know yet what the problems are going
to be but there's they're certain to be
problems so when I ignored your name
okay great there was i love the fair
mister
that's idea but the way in which you're
thinking about it so the outputs of
expert judgment right then the machine
is going to reason and define basically
define its own reasoning and that's
where like it's just a problem right
that that when we're thinking about why
a decision that an expert right has made
mum and it's the reasoning that we care
about not just that outcome and I know
for a fact that the machine is going to
learn a different reason for that out
and that's where the problem because I'm
that slippage is really problematic so
just to make sure I understand your so I
think the the point is we agree with
expert opinions and we think they're
valuable worth listening to
not just because like they're an expert
but because we think there's some valid
reasoning that goes behind the opinion
yeah I'm hot I'm a lawyer I want to hire
an associate I don't hand them a list of
decisions that I've made and say okay go
and make decisions because like I want
them to learn how I reach decisions okay
that's that's a really that's a good
analogy that helps me understand this a
lot I think that to me I guess what I'm
hearing sounds like kind of a problem
with all of machine learning not just
necessarily metrics with the with the
caveat that we're sort of imbuing the
metric with this like this is fairness
that it's kind of getting this
additional ethical umph because we
learned it from experts and therefore
it's fair is is that kind of the the
concern is that is that capturing
correctly the concern
if you said and I'm going to talk about
like if you said we want to avoid
certain outcomes and therefore I want
you to tell me what things are wrong and
avoid those in the future I'm for me if
you could map those out I'm more
comfortable using it as a way to prevent
unfairness than to model fairness so
what another way of saying that B I'm
happy with this to Aude it but I'm not
happy with this to determine what is
fair in the first place is that sort of
getting maybe I am misunderstanding I
think I don't know right yeah I think
the point is really well taken there is
a real danger of saying look I learned a
metric it's so awesome and just because
it's a metric and just because it's for
individual fairness now it like takes on
a life of its own and I think that is a
real danger of something like this and
something that I hope I can caveat
appropriately thirty tomorrow we will
have it seems another on the big